sister cassandra james has asked reading isaiah
57 verse 1 she sees that god will put many to
sleep for the time of trouble yes if a person died
and was not assured of where they stand with god
even though they have accepted him can such
a person rise up in the resurrection a person
a person who accepts christ will
have this certainty of salvation
because to accept christ it's accept salvation
christ is salvation are you following me yes
you're not accepting a doctrine you're accepting
a person the doctrine talks about the person
there are people with phd's and theology who don't
follow christ but they can explain the bible to
you to accept christ is to accept salvation so he
or she who has accepted christ truly has accepted
salvation and the assurance of your salvation lies
in the person you accepted not in what you do but
in the person you have accepted your assurance of
salvation is in jesus christ he's our wisdom our
righteousness our sanctification our redemption
first corinthians 1 13 30 so to accept christ is
to accept salvation christ complained in john 5
40 he will not come to me that he might have life
god has given to us eternal life this life
is in his son first john 5 11. so if a person
truly accepts christ the person has accept and the
presence of christ in you gives you that assurance
you can't build that assurance the presence of
christ in you gives you that assurance so someone
dies not sure he or she is saved the question has
to be asked did the person truly accept christ or
did the person simply accept the doctrine you know
stated by doctrines you're saved by a person let
me stress that again a person the doctrine simply
tells us about him but he himself is salvation
so if you accept christ you give your life to him
you believe without being able to explain how he
dwells within you then his presence in you creates
the assurance of salvation you cannot manufacture
that assurance it becomes arrogance and pride he
is the assurance amen you know i don't want to
belabor the point but i'm just thinking about
exodus chapter 33 and then going into chapter 34
where moses is like lord how do i know that
you are going to be with me to lead the people
to the promised land give me a sign show me
your glory and what did god do god proclaimed
his name to moses he he in fact the bible says
and the lord descended in the cloud and stupidly
his presence his presence his
indwelling presence is the assurance
his assurance is a person i don't mean
assurance is a person salvation is a person
conversion is a person it is all in christ
and when he's in you like alcohol he changes
the way you walk the way you think when you
see the way you speak he changes everything
if he is in you not just in the bible
in you he works from the inside out
amen let this mind be in you which
was also christ jesus okay all right
you